hi everyone before I start I should
acknowledge that this video is made in
collaboration with an Academy which is
the India's biggest online education
platform and they did a great job in
bringing all the educators all across
India under the same roof in the same
platform where you can learn from top
educators whenever you like whenever you
like now I'm really happy to say that
I'm launching a course on I teach am
biotechnology a crash course in this
course we would cover the whole syllabus
of iit-jee and biotechnology and the
topics that you really need to know
practice question in a span of two
months you can see my course page is
running in the an Academy Plus app now
in this course there would be five major
topics general biology biochemistry and
physiology cell biology and immunology
molecular biology and biotechnology and
at last but not least microbiology and
we would cover all these five topics in
a span of two month this month we would
be focused on cell biology immunology
and more towards molecular biology and
biotechnology because these are the two
most important aspects for Jam this year
now we would make a proper planning of
the course and that's how we would start
the course and we would have several
milestones that we would achieve
together course starts at the cellular
fast we would achieve our milestone by
December 15th the second milestone we
have to achieve in January sometimes as
we go along the course we would learn
all the topics that we need to cover all
the essential concepts for that and we
would practice problems there would be
online testing series in these platform
so I'm looking forward to that as well
the unique feature of this course is you
would get to see me solving a question
the thought process that is going inside
my brain I would directly share with you
that would help you to get idea how to
really tackle hard and difficult
questions and how to think about it in
comparative questions it's also
important what to leave or what not to
answer we would discuss all of those
topics in the
course now the course is designed in
such a way that after every three days
of course you have a doubt clearly
session and that's how the course is
structured which would give you a enough
time to grasp your concepts and clear
the doubts from that part it won't be
too much hectic but at the same time it
would give you a broad coverage it would
feel like that you are doing a group
study now
since an academy is online you can
anytime watch these videos by
downloading them but you would be able
to interact with me while I am live our
main motivation is the try ology of
study practice and recollect that's how
we can really grasp our concepts and
excel in this exam and the own line quiz
feature of this enacting whiplash part
platform it would really help you to get
to the stage when you can really be so
much flexible that in the final day it's
just easy for you so let's make a
motivation that together we learn and
let's crack IT share and I hope to see
you soon in the course just to say that
I had to make hours and hours time to
design this course so if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up please
share among with your friends and hope
to see you in on a Content platform as
well thank you